you
good morning
today's Mario Jay it's Mario time it's
rob time it's P and Rob time Peter uh
you gave this game a ten out of ten
yes it's a very big deal these are rare
and Mario is a rare game so we're gonna
show off a bunch of two players stuff
today which I don't think we've seen a
lot of before and we were kind of
surprised at how robust it is we're
gonna kick things off though by sort of
showing off the early portion of the
game yeah now to do some single players
to kind of you know riff a little bit
and show you what's games all about yeah
you're just kind of chilling right now
on the Odyssey sleeping as you can see
we were just talking about how elegant
that's Mario in a nutshell we were kind
of maker laughing how we think this is
probably the the sleepiest Mario of all
the games you leave it idle he goes to
sleep pretty freakin quick and mutters
things so let's pop the map here let's
see what we're working with mm-hmm so
this is the forest Kingdom and looking
at the map you can see this is sort of
like a pamphlet where you get lots of
interesting tidbits that are you know
useful for hunting down moons which are
this game's version of stars and
sometimes they're just kind of quirky to
look at and I love the writing in like a
no travel brochure as it obviously looks
like one - yes so the big deal with this
game is now
Mario's sentient hats that you can use
to possess enemies you can also use it
as a little platform but really
possessing is
and just NPCs in general is kind of the
selling point of the game because rather
than Mario having like suits that he
puts on he puts on the bodies of other
things all right so this is one of the
more elaborate costumes
thanks for good for destroying things
things are also good they can help you
get access to I don't yeah
and then within the game you'll find
like just you know each each capture
mechanic will kind of show up like I
feel like a lot more predominately in
like minigames like within tunnels and
underground stuff like it's I know my
first reaction moment when I was playing
was like oh there's only like a tank
level but in reality you can find any of
the captures in most stupid ways
throughout like the course of the game
again these series of minigames that are
kind of hidden so the deal is pretty
much anything that doesn't have a hat on
you can capture right so in some cases
like these guys they have a happy like a
melon got a veggie wrap fruit for those
of you who are just joining us for
points tomorrow Odyssey I'm looking at
the YouTube and twitch chat you guys
have questions right now we're just
gonna show off the game a little bit but
yeah I know someone was mentioning it
earlier there are leggings co-op in this
there is co-op in you and I loaded it up
the other day and found it pretty
intensive more so than I thought like
co-op in that there's more or less a
main player one the first person or
first players meat controlling mario
obviously and then the other player can
control the hat and it's not just like
something like mario galaxy where you're
like you know assisting in a small way
right Cappy just has free range of
movement with an analog stick he can
jump you can do things independent amar
it can be a little bit unwieldy because
you only have one camera to work with
right but still it's one of those things
where it's like alright I may not want
to play the entire game this way but for
like 10 minutes it's doing something
different
yeah learn more it's pretty fun so
almost a while in levels you'll find
these rockets
I love these rocket animations
especially when they come back through
the clouds it's just they're so like
they're so freakin fast I don't know oh
yeah so these take you either so there
really aren't that many distinct like
levels in this game so much as there are
you know random random levels like these
in open-world environments yes the time
is spent exploring an open world looking
for challenges of various types like you
will see like rooms of enemies where you
clear them out you get a moon and we'll
just see a moon hiding in a random spot
and you know but finding it can be part
of the challenge so it's it's a game
that sort of rewards you for things big
and small alike which is great you know
it kind of makes the game accessible for
all ages too and skill levels which
you've already been here I can tell yeah
you can tell so yeah this is you there
actually there is a way of doing like
five to five hard saves so I made the
call like at some point I saved somewhat
early on the game posting in the chat
asked how long is the game oh well about
I'm about 40 hours in yeah and I have
515 moons and there are 836 so I think
you could get at least 60 hours out of
this game I agree and if not more yeah
so shall we go to another Kingdom real
quick yeah explore there you can and we
can we can move around stays to show off
some costumes show off some awesome
costumes I won't have that many unlocked
but again it would not take long to go
through them safe yeah go to Neffe me so
yea you arrived you know we first art
playing the game you arrive at a Kingdom
and cap you'll be like hey we need you
know 10 moons to progress to the next
Kingdom and that's generally like I mean
how long is like you'd say like the main
questline
it's like not that long it's maybe 15
hours yeah but but that gets you through
you know obvious at 15 about 15 percent
of 20 percent of the available moons and
you get to an ending and you're like man
this game would by fast right but then
you realize okay not only have I not
collected all the moons that were
available but the game also introduces a
whole new set of moons in each Kingdom
which brings along new challenges that
are more difficult than the main game
and you also get some motivations to
collect them because you know the way
the game works is your Odyssey basically
needs to be powered up to do the next
thing and it'll ask for a certain number
of moons and after you beat the game
it's like okay I need you to get 250
moons and I basically beat it I think it
like 160 so it's a it's a pretty
significant bump and then it goes to 500
after that and you like crap like what
is left there and the surprises that you
do unlock you know they lead to perhaps
the true ending of the game if you will
yeah but also some challenges that you
didn't really see before and all of that
just kind of spurs you along to keep
playing
if you didn't already want to because
this game is just fantastic to play it
is just for fun you'd be proud of really
accomplishing anything I just like being
in this world is Mario controlling Mario
has like never felt as good it's it's
freaking unreal as a huge 64 fan like
it's funny to like just like pull up
those synapses of like the long jumps
and like triple jumps like it just
happened so immediately
so this oh we got pulled into an early
as our boss by it so we could probably
bounce out this is maybe spoilery just
some people if we do if we do we want to
show Bowser
let's get first 5 comments what do you
think ed you guys want to see so this is
not the final Bowser fight no this is
like a couple hours oh it's just like a
couple hours in the game if you guys
want to see it let us know people
talking in the chat about how co-op
works it's actually not like galaxy it's
a little bit more elaborate and we'll
show you that in just a few minutes gube
says show it that's one I love that spin
way it's only one vote come on
can i alright well we'll just pop out
then I guess no one else really wants to
do this why don't you put a change of
your clothes someone else oh alright
alright let's change first yeah put on
some appropriate battles malgor says f
and do it everyone and I'll just flocked
in ok cool we're doing it thanks guys
alright so this is just a few right I
mean there are over 30 yeah this is my
favorite the Famicom mechanic outfit
from Famicom grand through 3d rally 2 on
the Famicom disk system right but it's
so awesome that they could like make
that call back like their last that
there are a few things in this game that
really do lean into the tent Nintendo's
Japanese roots which I find kind of I
don't know whatever I guess I'm some
sort of weed but enough right
alright let's go kick some
Bowser ass I love these inflatable
mattresses that's exactly what they look
like
holy SH they last 48 hours then they
constantly deflate so the story setup
here is very new
Bowser steals peach yeah but it you know
it goes to a place that it's not like a
huge revelation for the series but it's
an interesting little if not like
head-scratching
ending to the you know the first ending
of the game right it's interesting and
it actually does go places it does yeah
and that's not sarcasm no
all right Mary oh yeah that's so
adorable
oh yeah I'm coming in the crotch
lynx-o says everyone has awesome hats
it's pretty true yeah it's kind of thing
in this game
all right
hello I'm coming
I actually
what so maybe we talk a little bit about
the motion controls if there is like and
it's it's not even a big big deal really
but it's the only but it's the only
thing that I can actually reach towards
as far as anything that you could find a
sort of maybe a slight gripe with this
game because otherwise I actually do
find it like pretty much perfect it's
very close to it for what it tries to do
yeah like it just feels so great but the
motion controls alluding to there are
obviously a Arsenal moves mario has I
want to say two of them require you to
shake or use the motion whether maybe
joy Khan's or just you know the pro
controller yeah because you can you can
fling copy obviously but you can also
fling him in different ways that help
you collect things in your environment
and you can throw him up and you can
throw him down but you can't do those at
that motion controls right which is a
bit of a bummer and it's not really a
huge deal because the sort of key things
that you have to do to progress in the
game they don't really ask me for that
it's more or less than hey I see a weird
you know coin in this area I want to
collect or something you know you have a
secondary objective right now obviously
every switch has these motion
controllers at the ready all I gotta do
is pop them off and do it and put them
back if you really need to do that yeah
there were maybe six instances total so
far where I felt you need to do that
yeah but even so there's because he's
got such a like a variety of means of
like traversal like you can work around
it it's never like that frustrating but
it's just funny to think like if you're
playing handheld and it's you're shaking
it like that's terrifying to think I
don't know I'm just rattling your switch
and it or letting it fly do it I'm so
excited about Mario yeah
well do we want to
move out of this world and go it's like
a later stage my favorite solvents but
fine
oh it's is it in this one the lot
forgotten lost kingdom forgotten Isle
yeah this is the same vulture who takes
your hat 64 did I haven't played many of
the other Mario games unfortunately I
never owned own like a Wii U or a Wii
but anyways does that vulture ever come
in any other other games is it just 64
yeah I have a really crappy memory so
again if you guys have any questions in
the chat
feel free to don't add me don't at me
let him rip Peter how many hours you can
keep played so far 60 40 40 I'm saying
you can get 60 yes sure these guys I
like I like those guys yeah the New York
City I think you're speaking of new dog
city but yeah we should totally go there
that's probably I know there's no stigma
at today's like what's my favorite level
like I wanted to say was the wooded
Kingdom would last one then there's some
about new dog city just running around
that that's got some of the best like
climbing and freerunning it's gonna like
yeah and it's got a really good so yeah
it does there's a lot of verticality and
yeah a really good sort of like energy
going on as well right everything is
just sort of like upbeat there's a lot
of activities like things to look at a
lot of weird people and yeah and some
kingdoms you'll definitely find yourself
spending more time in okay maybe this
one this you know it's a really awesome
level but you know the game isn't afraid
to basically explain that like you know
you'll see it like some levels will have
50 of the currency purple specific
tokens or some will have a hundred
feel like a hundred loose yep there are
something that one hundred and as far as
moons are concerned there's one that has
104
there are plenty that have over 50 and
there's a lot a lot of moons 836 to be
precise yeah more time all right i'ma
get these last coins and then I think we
should load another save and go to
alright try to player there I think
that's a good place to get new dog it's
a perfect place we'll show the two
player oh yeah you guys got questions a
whole bunch of um resolution in TV mode
1080p or 720p my capture kit was saying
1080p signals yeah are there any
mechanics Scoob asks are there any
mechanics that make you back travel or
can you get everything right away I mean
the mechanics are derived by the enemies
that you run into and you can't take
them which one you want going to save ya
go to go to lake Kingdom okay
you can't take a captured enemy out of
the environment because the only way to
go from one Kingdom to another is by
using copy and copy is the key to
staying connected to an enemy so you
know the kingdoms give you everything
that you need to complete all the
challenges right and and you brought
this up in your review in that you the
first time you arrive at a kingdom it's
not gonna look exactly the same
throughout your entire play like they
change all the time due to like your
impact on the world and then after
especially after you complete the main
story every Kingdom is worth revisiting
multiple times I mean you could spend
probably ten hours in some of the bigger
kingdoms yeah and you know trying to
collect everything that's there and do
that before moving on to the next yeah
but then again once you beat the you
know the sort of the first story mode
that whatever you you will then get more
[Music]
total hours completionist well dan
reycarts dan record yeah we've gotten
every single moon in the game and he did
it in the same span of time that we did
but I don't know how many hours it took
him he was also just beast voting this
game he was I mean I was I was trying to
but it was all stuff like it's a crazy
review season right now
yes week in particular so I've been you
know like all of us at GameSpot kind of
just running around like a crazy person
right and I think for those are you know
a man is a Mario maniac yeah Mario mania
that's what I'm looking for
here's a here's a damn good question
Owen McClain asks would you recommend
buying this game with the switch because
I'm thinking about buying the bundle I
totally would yeah I think you know like
one of the things about this game is
that it just didn't it
it knows how to make you feel like a kid
again and it know you know it's sort of
for me when I started playing it reset
my my current outlook on the state of
like video games at the end of 2017 like
Ryan there's so many just dark and
foreboding and violent things out there
and that's always the case and then
that's been the case for years
but Mario can be enjoyed it you don't
have to be a kid to really like it like
Ryan you have to be an adult to get even
more of its funnier moments it's just
it's it's just innocent joy and fun and
if you like video games for you know
feeling having a broad range of feelings
and stuff like this game will satisfy
what a game like Wolfenstein can't so I
think - with a switch would be like
giving yourself a Christmas
so Christmas when the 64 came out oh
yeah you'd be that kid that kids
screaming yeah I totally agree and you
know it's funny he's not even talking
about Zelda 1 Zelda came out I was asked
that question and you know what like I
had to dial back because I personally
just had the exact same feeling and this
game totally does the same but that the
feeling of like feeling like a kid but
also wishing I didn't hit like there's
some times where I was like I I'm so
happy that there is a kid playing this
game like you're right somewhere yes the
saddle that makes me like yeah super
happy because it's like you get playing
in 74g and grew into this right and
support things like this right that will
continue like I remember what ocarina of
time did to me and but at that time it
was just Delta that came out and I was
the only like actual game that came out
switch and now that question is asked
and I'm like yeah yes I think it is safe
to say that getting a switch is
absolutely worth it and you got tons of
other games coming down the road my god
doom and Skyrim Skyrim I think are
coming out Skyrim I know that's grabbed
me so much no wonder that let's gonna
look but doom I mean that that was a
couple years ago was that last year it
was last year last year all right I'm
gonna go kill a hooker and 208 yeah this
is weird stuff seeing humans as weird
wild stuff wild wacky stuff they have
the strangest things to say with the
strangest boys no you had it at that low
hold it in hold oh that's that guy Peter
oh this is actually like hard to control
yeah it was glad there weren't many
sections of this because this is not my
favorite part of the game right it's
like 10 seconds whatever but I'm happy
that it's in like another minigame that
if you came across right I mean that's
just it there's so many variety of
things like you know one or two crappy
ones
get out of the way this guy in here I
can talk to one new worker I got these
any time limit on hat control so you can
throw it and hold on to it I want to say
for how long I think you can do it
longer than that oh yeah I feel like
I've been able to do it indefinitely you
should change your fit you should what
controller is best for this game the pro
controller although no I guess like that
yeah the per controllers best like the
the joint cons are actually just as good
in terms of functionality but and the
per controller is just a great
controller all-around so that's why
people want to see some co-op so we'll
do that yeah my god that aviator fit is
like okay I'll do it for you or come I
know it looks really good
if I do so say myself combine it with
the Builder suit I think it looks great
this one yeah yeah I think that looks
super great is that just fantastic isn't
that special all right
and the real awesome part about
two-player is that it's just
instantaneous more questions
kiss Joan oh clickbait title someone
says okay well we're gonna show it right
now yeah so I'm gonna be controlling
capi crappy oh I had to double-check my
review like a hundred times to misread
crappy - okay I don't know
we are not into Claire yet oh did I just
swoop first person by accident no yeah
go back out okay Oh weird okay
there we go okay so hey I was like we
appreciate how Cappy just sort of hovers
around Mario's head rather than on it so
I we press okay well last time we did
this I was Mari and you were the Hat so
I'm trying to trying to learn trying to
learn you all right be a crappy Kathy so
Rob is just controlling Cappy as he will
and I can just take I could just leave
which I usually like to do it was so
funny yesterday we were like can we try
it yeah let's try it out and we were
like oh my god you had full control of
Cappy I posted like you know the same
exact response as you wouldn't
single-player just by the row cover for
me oh my god I can look around myself -
oh yeah let's come here oh my god all
right you know
so now oh I have to press the L trigger
you know no you do
oh I do what you mean hey whoop the pros
here I love it
alright look at all their moons what I
can't I have just that those are yeah I
was thinking that too whoa how much so
you know when you first start playing
this game you see like sections like
this you're like okay I need to move
this thing to get to this part of the
platform but you don't like you can you
can actually be really creative of how
you use Cappy and Mario is just innate
abilities to get from point A to point B
in ways that don't seem immediately dude
I'm not just saying this this is this is
an actual co-op experience yes like I
thought it was just like a snack on but
like you could no more because I haven't
played Kappa but the morning thing about
it like this would be actually the whole
damn game like this good I'm sure people
will get down here oh if I can knock you
off maybe cool I like all those larvae
they're just hanging out and they see
you they're like alright I'm gonna I'm
gonna become a fly now okay yeah oh
all right let's expedite this so how do
you uh I know you were doing it how I
can raise my height okay oh it's not
that high okay
oh wait oh no Milt I'm sorry what is
that stuff gak number deck
oh damn it is gak I used to troll my
grandfather by stepping outside of his
apartment and like hanging outside the
window gak farting farting yes six oh
you can make it fart that's right that
was my idea
right also GEX although I'm sure it's
like just hitting some countries yeah
the bottom of the barrel gackt let's
let's create an off-brand well owed to
God thanks for joining man yeah the one
thing I wouldn't say it's bad but I just
to note is that I cannot command you to
come back to me you cannot do that right
so I can't just like press a button and
make you return that's good that's part
of the co-op experience teamwork
communication oh no
Mario not good Mario I blame the game I
would regret my ten out of ten let's get
it I don't have this area damn okay what
do you want to do you can do let's go to
the top of the building or something
like that
ah I think you do that right now
it's funny think compared to Zelda like
we talked about the other day just like
comparing those games they're like they
are similar and different in many ways
but it's like funny weather when they're
exact opposite opposite so it's like in
Zelda you could warp out at any point so
in this game there's so many times we're
all paused after like falling or in
midair and it's like nah you got to be
still on a safe safe area Oh
[Laughter]
waiting to be like all right so what are
we gonna do this football too slow
that's all you okay this is you know but
you did the capture
I love the anything you you what the
flicking is so far it is yeah kind of
like real-life John Koeppen Stein wants
to know if I've so far but the game it's
a game that you should play and if you
don't have a switch you should buy a
switch to play it it's time I don't know
what else to tell you it's it's time
yeah I think it's time what DK
I mean DK says record thinks it's better
than 64 I think in a modern context yeah
yeah I mean like if I had to pick one
you know this game or Mario 64 to play
right now right this game there's just
there's just so many things to do and
we're not really doing a great job of it
right now because really hunting for
moons is the thing to do so maybe we
should do that but Mario 64 is this
doesn't like negate that game like it's
still right really good but I just I
just have I have more immediate fun
playing that's yeah absolutely
all right um do we have the moon list
unlocked here the moon list we can go
different save no that's fine I'm just
trying to see like do you have the moon
cube moves no yours okay now so this is
this is this oh let's let's go find toad
and ask him for help yeah we've already
got some help okay oh cool
all right so I'm gonna go there head
east excuse me have you seen you know a
princess and a dinosaur jerk we're
looking for a nice glowy moon what is
this oh my god oh geez tough one
did you do the one with the crowds of
people what do you mean the mini-game
like just like that we enter of the door
and there's like a bunch of people
well thanks oh my god we have to try and
find it it's freakin hilarious
we gotta go in every single room here
what wait let me get this started the
thing we were talking about it ain't
over here where is it oh I got to go up
top
alright I'm gonna go to the heliport I'm
gonna go to the heliport jsm 7 7 7 7 so
player 2 controls a hat yeah I'm
controlling the Hat with a control key
you can also use you know we are lucky
enough to have two Pro controllers but
you can have just the right joy Khan
just the joy Khan's is really all you
need so one would each person would get
one
whoa you just generate a motor scooter
no he says Park it here that's that's a
stud you know that's a moon that's a
moon I said this is the sort of thing
where you realize that yeah right as
Robbie's put two and two together like I
need to figure out how to make this
happen right but also yeah it looks okay
so yeah so clearly you can get scooter
up there for sure oh that's me I'm sorry
yeah so both players that control the
camera which does make this a little bit
unwieldy especially if you're an
impatient man like myself but again I'm
working on it I'm working but again like
it's not like a half-assed add-on by any
means go kick that football let you do
it this time thanks for your vote of
confidence damn it you're right my ball
my ball
occasionally sail occasionally one one
word right right I get some plan O'Quinn
final fantasy yet this is too easy it's
an easy game for a lot of you know what
you're doing but it's it's meant to be
sort of like a playground you do
absolutely find things that are
challenging so you know just because
it's easy a lot of the time it doesn't
mean that a you're not having fun and B
there aren't difficult things to look
forward to yeah if you're not having fun
with even with the easy stuff I worry
for your heart and soul
so he wanted to go try to find the weird
people oh it's so funny I was laughing
my ass off go you know so I'm actually
fairly sure I wish it showed I think
with the moon west yes keep going down
oh I didn't even find the moon over
there I was supposed to be looking for
go back northwest corner of you got a
boss sour says this map looked bigger in
previews man I'm never playing the
preview and this was pretty much the
same thing I would say it's Tendo did a
good job of marketing it to make it look
big I will say that also I've never been
in this before dude I remember I came in
I was like what
so you actually pull the lever now I'm
just having fun
yeah it's it's so weird and strange and
what all right let's pull over any hey
you know what the framerate is like
taking like a very tiny hit Oh some
framerate
it's real solid yeah it is definitely
real solid this is the only place not
this room but Metro Kingdom is the only
place where I've seen a frame retaken
hitch and it's stupid humans all right
you already had that moon anyway yeah so
yeah for the most part like oh you know
I guess you'd call this a mini game for
sure does the game specify what these
are exactly they're just fun yeah but
for the most part there's like there's
always a moon and then I would say
there's like at least another hidden
I don't know if you've had any regular
life there wasn't a second move I feel
like every time super rare yeah like if
you go into location and you see a moon
go get it but then the only don't just
leave like like take the time to really
look around your environment right trash
and the other thing too is if you go
back into said minigame Cappy will
either say hey there's nothing here or I
think there's another moon left in this
area did it pay your check 15% is an
acceptable tip but 20 is more you wanna
go get your moon yes moon someone asked
how many kingdoms or worlds are there
[Music]
oh we could do the SCOOTER one two after
is this thing oxy you're right
yup oh it's up on that stop look at the
devil a civil engineer you're welcome
yeah why don't you I want to try oh I'm
trying to give you a little a little
jump you can't do it infinitely that's
the thing oh you are come on Pete come
on Pete come on Pete oh you not to photo
mode when you're instant to player I
guess that makes man staying which is
also really cool I was yeah a nice
oh damn Rob they found us out they paid
us for this review why did you put you
put in your review you're not supposed
to yeah hide that stuff thanks for the
check I think I wrote thanks for the
check well it was worth it because I got
a lot of money yeah I mean I could
basically be discredited at this point
and like I could retire rich yeah
all right shall we go to a New Kingdom
let's show the SCOOTER cuz it's so
freakin fun go Mikkel are you rode that
scooter it's to the right
Demarest are you yeah there's a few
not here though if you want me to do it
again I won't come it's over here
GTA eat your heart app whoa I'm here to
collect money for although if you can't
afford it we've got a job for you
let me see peach
oh we did this I wish you I wish you
could abort friendships Oh like engaging
those like scarecrow ones or other kind
of shorter puzzles yeah it's better
different Kingdom I think
[Music]
I work for the city can you get off that
pole okey-dokey
all right so where do you want to be now
well I think we should change our outfit
yeah oh uh press a to abort friendship
what do moons do ask John they give you
a sense of satisfaction and they help
power up the Odyssey so you can travel
into kingdoms and the unlock outfits for
purchase within the sort of general
store yeah yeah um moons you want them
is the Sailor outfit from a Mario game I
don't know it's like I wonder like how
many of these are a lot of them are and
they aren't mm-hmm no I I'm not really
sure about the Sailor one that I'm
trying to think of something this one's
your favorite I hate this one there are
a couple costumes I don't like I feel
like they deviate from there so we hear
cool Mario really is I mean this works
yes this was this was a cancelled Mario
game rady was a world war two pilot
fighting Nazis I kind of wanna do the
Mario Paint outfit but I don't think I
see it
well we can go to a different sure do it
delete Oh God let's go the big one the
big cheese yeah let's do it yeah this
was a good world I think see seaside oh
we can show off that cute cute little
pup yes okay I'm glad we came here
yeah this is one of the
so yeah boy we can say nothing oh
nothing that the dog works dog so first
of all he'll lead you to like a thing to
be like hey I was pooping earlier and
burying my poop but I found this thing
so let me just give that to you but then
he sort of your buddy he's there to play
and he'll he'll come on board I feel
like he is his own man or a girl but he
he'll be huh well he'll be on the
Odyssey sometimes yeah like I this guy
just does whatever he wants
we got DK asking what's the ratio
between well-crafted platforming arenas
and just running around aimlessly
so platforming is I would say about a
third of the game but aimlessly is it
necessary or maybe maybe more than a
third aimlessly I don't know if that
accurately describes I mean we've been
doing it Amos Lee because we've gotten
so many moves and we're just kind of
having fun here but almost every single
thing we've seen the game be it like a
landmass or a building is there for a
reason to provide you with a way to get
moons or hidden coins I mean yes sure
this Rock doesn't do anything special
but you know pretty much everything else
like you know any major thing you're
looking at leads to a moon leads to a
challenge of some sort which maybe
platforming in a minor sense at times
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
that this game isn't all about
traditional Mario platforming at least
in my mind
bring it here come on yeah it is the
mismatch as momentary I don't know why
yeah you guys can see air controllers we
both have Pro controllers I'm the Hat
Peter here is Mario the guy in the in
the red what does that remind you of
squid that's all you're reminded this is
my favorite thing I think when I forget
this Oh Mario oh we should also there's
a 2d thing I like yeah I just loved the
idea of running out of water with this
thing oh it's really yeah I'm gonna run
out of water and show you it's because
you're severely impaired wait oh you're
on water
now shake your controllers yeah so oh
that's the other thing is like this hat
oh yeah oh that gonna make catchin
bunnies oh you're right what does the
Hat do separately is the question well I
mean really it's it's there you go this
is pretty clutch you ready to go yeah
baby born ready
yeah ultimately I mean the Sun flare can
just control the Hat really I mean
everything else is the same as far as
the mechanics involved
it's so funny to see the the green
salmon a wheel like a 6hr red-yellow but
from press the wild
lord helix Cooper is asking so whoever
plays the hack and capture enemies by
himself yes
and that also means that if you capture
an enemy and Mario is you know
possessing that enemy the second player
can also make Cappy leave to possess
something else you can actually hop
between enemies with two players
which is not something you can do in
single-player it's pretty cool and here
we go again this is some of the you know
retro 8-bit style Super Mario Brothers
game play there's also something in here
it's got to be no happy oh there's a
Senate hidden block right there yeah
there's something so rewarding about
like trying each costume or outfit out
in 8-bit yeah I love it reflected but a
good number of them at least I don't
think all of them are oh I haven't had
waiting like like you've entered and
it's not the costume that you were
wearing yes but you know what now that I
actually think about it I wonder if
that's because I was mixing it magic but
yes they're having and then it just
chooses the outfit I post that just
gives you the default world okay so
maybe that's what it was that would make
sense
yeah I'm getting you all these moons
yeah look at me I did not sleep enough
see though and now we have to go do it
all again
[Music]
I love these like fish or swimming over
here you know we'll do anything they
don't hurt you know they're just there
if they're just there for aesthetic I
think you have to go through the yeah I
just wanted to get that blonde also I
keep wanting to do Mario's like backflip
on another pressure yeah
let's let's look at that moon
oh sorry can you use single joy cons for
two players absolutely mm-hmm I went
unpaid to try one so you got to go right
let's see the people leaving chat I'm an
FM t-rex says it's me it's a me too
welcome to chat though thank you for
joining yeah yeah we are currently just
watching me play but we'll go back to
the two players stuff and how many
fights would break out with two players
let's get yeah I get a bunch of it No oh
yeah yeah for sure so that's so that's
like another plus two player right is
like so you know you can get three of
these but it's kind of difficult playing
single-player because the Hat is
obviously gonna return on its own but
now you can collect three and it's not
power it's just long long long Jeff Jeff
'ti yeah there's one little left here
and get one more I think
oh I thought this is what I was okay
here to go just three max I don't know
oh boy that's four I've never done four
before alrighty never been more ready
gotta go fast
Oh
by my stuff yeah
let's talk about moons for a second you
can buy unlimited moons after you beat
the first ending of the game Oh perfect
shall we oh this is this is a perfect
screen you guys are gonna love this yeah
this may be so happy I know like I heard
it and it's just what yeah and there are
a couple more costumes that you and I do
it ooop just wore back to the ICU yeah
like the end game I mean I don't even
know what that looks like but there are
tons tons of costumes to look forward to
that like I've heard about but have not
seen myself there's a couple yeah yeah
but back to the buying moon thing I just
want to address that real quick so it
seems like a very strange thing given
that the whole game is about earning
wigs but you know if you go back to the
idea that moons help you unlock items in
the store and power up your ship it's
actually a very convenient thing to be
able to buy them because what that lets
you do is you know progress if either
you are tired of a certain Kingdom I
don't know why it would be or if you you
know there's a hat you really want to
buy and you're already at the store and
you don't want to go back out and look
for movies you can just buy a couple and
do it that way what it does not do is
remove moons from the world it's not
like you're sort of buying a moon in
place of a challenge that would give you
a moon right thankfully because that
would be too bad and when you were
describing it to me the first time I
like cuz I didn't know you could do that
just continually by because yeah that's
very unlike I mean comparisons like Mars
before for me at least it's like oh
that's I want that set amount right but
but it's fine everything's fine it's all
good and there's the other Mariah
probably I think it might be my favorite
costume
I'm good look at it maybe later gube
asking is impossible to just buy the max
moons it's possible you would have to be
a crazy person to try to do that also I
don't think there is a maximum number of
moves I think you can probably just keep
buying them
maybe 999 or something so right and I so
you guys sorry what they don't see right
now is my controllers vibrating and I'm
trying to hunt for a moon based on my
vibration mine too actually
sorry we both can do this that's pretty
fun there's something right here Oh
[Music]
teamwork it's funny is I can actually I
didn't I know if I told you this is uh I
I got to 9999 coins doing a slot game in
Metro Star new dock city it took me I
want to say I was getting about a
thousand coins every twenty minutes now
when I I did the test and I was trying
to get a costume but uh I went back to
save and and it used all those coins to
see how many like moons I could get and
it was like it just didn't feel that
worth it like I think I mean it was like
what maybe like 100 moons but for the
amount of time I spent like it's not
enjoyable yeah just be doing that yeah
it's just not again it's like good in it
I feel like I'm just rephrasing or
restating things for my review sure it's
helpful in a pinch it's inefficient and
boring to rely upon
so in that sense it doesn't really
detract from I don't I should go to New
Kingdom yeah we should
nassim says also did I see a Super Mario
cool what's another fun area to go to we
could go
I I was thinking that I'm tempted but I
don't know I don't I don't know if we
should
shirtless Mario in the snow kingdom yep
I went there and you get a moon from
someone who's like damn dude look at you
in your underpants in this cold okay I'm
gonna give you a moon because I respect
the [ __ ] out of that crazy bastard
very foul language for a more he just
that one guy to welcome is pretty good
luncheon Kingdom is pretty good I was
gonna say that or oh should we show them
the races and the snow Kingdom
did you go back and do it and doing like
another round of it yeah okay well you
do that I don't remember how to get to
it that we'll have to look for it's you
go into there like town and then you
drop down again
look at all those stickers I got slapped
on my Odyssey
yeah it probably isn't totally cool
gorgeous honesty is the best policy oh
man yeah you can control a t-rex real
early on that was my favorite it's like
oh you're giving me the tears now oh my
god they're like yeah double F triple F
is saying WOW a lot of the moons look
extremely simple to get yes but again
there are eight hundred and thirty six
of them and again like 40 hours in I'm
still finding them and even just as
discovering easy ones in that way is I
promise you I promise you it feels
rewarding because you feel like I've
been here a hundred times how did I miss
that moon this is a thing you can
possess its moon cube okay so after you
beat which took I did it in a day after
you beat sort of the main story mode the
games you see these cubes in the world
anyway
but after beating the game they sort of
glow and you can activate them and they
shoot brand new moons out into every
Kingdom right if you do this once per
Kingdom and what's actually nice too is
that because you've spent so much of
this game and up until that point
looking for a moon to blindly this when
it spits them out as you'll see will
actually pinpoint them on your map so
you have this sort of these two paces to
the game one is open world exploration
just totally on your own whim and then
the other one is this more directed
Waypoint oriented situation
someone mentioned the eels from 60 or 64
then there are they are in here and yes
they are I would argue even more
petrifying well I kind of want to let
Mario's sleep so it pengon Alana's nose
but I think so I think those are the
only birds in this kingdom right yeah we
should made it happen so quickly we can
we were kind of laughing about before
the stream how quickly Mario can sleep
well no he actually might not because
he's cold it in the heat in the heat I
wasn't sleep you will die
oh you can't swim for two yeah you can't
oh here let's do that let's do that you
sure yeah why not nice function nice
okay so these are some of the more
difficult platforming sections that open
up this one looks to be about a give it
seven or an eight oh no this one's more
of a six soon but there are a lot of
these extra platforming sections that
rip it up after you
we got this
I'm your hype man and this in this
minigame damn look at you chase those
flowers [ __ ] oh oh that could have been
you rob
you could have capture way too well yeah
don't forget I got that thank you one
thing I can do oh damn I can't talking
about it no I can't
nah this is not this is not my game this
is all you so those are bullet bills
there are the bigger ones call something
else
ricochet Richards right oh I'm sorry
weapon Williams I like to say Richard
nice so there probably is a second one
in here a second right Rob let's let's
see if we find it there is great we said
the same thing at the same time mate all
right well next we'll come back at
another time you write that down all
right let's go do a race oh right
fans i bill that's right
these guys are awesome
also oh do you want me to get you the
underwear yeah oh you got changed though
huh I like changing cool
I love the soundtrack I love how it's
like a weird and apologize if I'm wrong
but like Celtic soundtrack for this yeah
oh Kingdom like why but it works well I
was trying to like a lot of the kingdoms
you can like identify like the culture
that they're inspired by like like we
were at the seaside one that's like
clearly like a like a South France beach
town yeah
was it nice it's my love your knees nice
yeah yeah yeah oh is it legit monolith
nice yeah wonder one no I'm being honest
is that like the actual city they
because I know they spoke out about like
the Italian theme for the luncheon
Kingdom I'm actually not sure okay it's
just uh that was my point of reference
and I might not even really understand
these atolls no I've been a nice
actually so it it is very reminiscent to
that tight did it but yeah this this
world it's it I mean yeah so I'll take
sounds about right
no I missed that that's fine wait what
was it no I I wasn't paying attention to
the side quest for those or the mood you
just got for those talking who's talking
is this game good is it like Mario 64
Peter this looks a lot like Mario 64 but
you don't actually race on your bum you
can race in a very different way this is
good luck Mario 64 it is an open-world
Mario game with lots of surprises and
lots of things like stars to collect but
it's also very different the pacing is
much more generous you get rewards and
new things very frequently and I dare
say it's a better game I dare say it's
you know it's been a while since I was
16 for but yeah if memory serves me what
am I going toward the races and feel
like I'm you guys you are you are no no
yes yes nope
describe it to me describe to me know
your back we started I think it's guys
have to talk to someone
yeah I think you engaged this oh you got
a possess oh that's right so this is how
that sort of bouncing thing where do I
go to I just talked to the dude to the
right
Jefferson Castro hi from Brazil hello
whatever joining us what up hey did you
know that GameSpot Brazil is now a thing
yeah I'd actually had forgot about that
right let's talk to our friend of Brazil
yeah glad you chimed in to thank you oh
this is circuit class s I don't know
what that means but I'm in it to win it
so the trick you do these little
bounding things and you want to sort of
do it at the rail you don't want to hit
the snow you want to do it at the right
angle to bridge the gaps right yeah it's
like when you get on this slope here
it's just like a hard left
these guys are good here yeah sounds
like banjo
Rex oh oh you can also shake the
controller you shake the controller a
lot when you're possessing someone what
I'm really happy with what I'm doing I
just get really excited for sure I
actually the only time you really need
to shake it is when you are riding the
electric lines you will sort of that's
another another like move that I I
learned so late it kind of bummed me out
I was like oh that's supposed to do I
like for for so long I thought you had
to like just like jump off shirt it's a
lot sweaty no no okay I sweat things
that should be a good song from the past
[Music]
dot-mpeg you you just tune in for a
quick little mini game here we have been
playing co-op hosted the stream
something tonight
not sure why maybe you thought there
were two Mario's the co-op portion of
the game is the second character
controls Mario's hat we've littered
we've literally just take a short
diversion to show off this race
oh there you go
are you equipment of gas
that's Ali she's she's got moves
she's done two championships the dad was
a founder
so talk to me about this if you had to
pick one could you and would you or
would you just throw them both away and
say no I can't do it's super tough for
me because I don't like you know it's
just like to me it's apples and oranges
this was a trick question you answered
it correctly high-five and also you got
first place
good job oh is that good but if I were
to pick it beat someone
it's crazy these these two games though
like yeah they sort of like follow
similar paths but do things in their own
way you did the moon what else we got we
can show I was gonna say we could do the
brother racing thing but I don't know if
that's two-player yeah let's go to
luncheon Kingdom the brother reason the
Goomba the Koopa Troopa brother oh yeah
or is it in this room no it can't be
this is oh is just a tracing game yeah
this is kind of time
oh this is tough there's no one's tough
well but it's I think it's a triangles
oh yeah cuz I've done these in like
sometimes you'll have like a frame of
reference right like a crater or
something that did yeah so my girlfriend
loves watching me screw up in video
games and loves to say here so I have a
good time no no hey trust I have a good
time doing because the circle ones are
about [ __ ]
the circle was a real tough and I was
like babe check it out the circle ones
are tough okay
just one more time and then we'll do
we'll go to the because legend kingdom
you just call you a mustache man yeah I
am a mustache man good oh no that's real
bad I worked 16 hours yesterday as did
you I think we're both a little sleep oh
my god last night I was Mario thick just
look at that rock describe it to me yeah
we can let's go to lunch even I'm hungry
for some lunch oh my god I will say
luncheon Kingdom when I first arrived
and I was when I first arrived and was
balancing on a corn cob I was like oh
like cause I gotta eat
[Laughter]
delicious it was delicious I ate Top
Ramen
no I didn't what did I just do what are
you gonna say probably lunch
all right as the money point Mario
shouldn't be having fun he needs to save
the princess reminds me of a boy named
Li was about to say the same we should
be snowboarding you should be saving I
don't know an entire kingdom the I'm the
funniest like memes I've ever seen ever
laughing so hard was it was like an
image of Zelda for brother while I think
I've been waiting for a hundred years
like a hundred years like come save me
and then no Anders it cuts and it's
linked on a go-kart from where are you
late alright I'm gonna get the painters
outfit because that's my fav I love I
love the chef one as well the chef one
is good yeah it's from Mario cook
Yoshi's cookie the painting one is from
Mario Paint and I just like to see the
more obscure Mario games it's in love
that was only humans who had the deepest
voice like which one go back that's the
first human like it's just so for
anything like no human in the world and
real life sounds like this guy
it's like terrifying that is Edison here
[Music]
resurrected on to the Giant you are not
human that you were wearing human skin
Camero says luncheon King lunch Kingdom
now I'm hungry I know I'm gonna be both
I know it's not even lunchtime it's
always lunchtime ooh too short sorry too
short - I got you I'll go get some well
together we shall accomplish I should
have spent much time - nice hat Mario I
keep forgetting that I'm actually well
we've been doing a lot of single-player
stuff yeah after the last few minutes
but yeah we are for those who join us we
are doing a little co-op here I can
control the cap break those boxes baby
you got it oh nice this will assist
[Music]
like a choice to make these so polygonal
oh yeah go with what you know Rob you
gotta get fire there how do you get
fired there alright should we do that
let me get that let me get the Hat and
then we'll do it what do you want me to
do what you want the Hat we go by the
mario the painter hat oh you've got
sorry I'm going out i bad bowser is the
protagonist Mario is the antagonist it
is a crazy mixed-up topsy-turvy world we
live in but hey Troy Oliver says I
subscribed thank you very much man they
appreciate it do any outfits have
special abilities so just happy
accidents the short answer is no you
will come across okay like you actually
in this world I'll show you there's one
right there's a locked door and I'll
they'll have a not even a riddle to be
like hey you should you know only shifts
are allowed in here so it's you know
obviously you need to be wearing the
chef's outfit this smock and and what's
behind these doors are basically those
mini games like a moon or two but that's
it for the most part but and you know
you know you obviously wanna make the
comparison to Zelda Zelda has obviously
those crazy
status boosts and stuff but I don't know
you really just come to love like there
is still such a sense of like drive to
get costumes and wear them yeah the ones
that are corresponding and appropriate
for like the worlds like Mario is a
character right and like even if these
only have a superficial different
difference that kind of helps shape
Mario's character is your perception of
for me I'm a simple man look yeah
all it takes is a shirt and I look at
you totally different oh man I'm just
remembering the tomatoes that you need
to use in smanos sure so Rob you can
yeah you can help oh my god these guys
are so funny the ones that throwing the
pans yeah we can find some Oh God I
don't know you but I was laughing when I
was pretty good when I was spamming
their their Panthro it's so funny so you
can go capture one from here okay now I
don't I don't have that rule I can never
die so so the thing is is it the hit the
game when you first possess these that
it says like you can also shake the
controller to throw faster dude you
throw so much faster when you shake it I
was just laughing my ass off
also it's a well-known fact that she can
win broken down thank you they're so
cute
I am a hat says talk told you yeah and
the different types of again if you guys
are just joining us oh yeah so this is
really great too so this is obviously
something you do not want to touch
however let's start to see the puzzle
element so here this lets me traverse
and potentially solve a puzzle which I
well I mean I've already kind of been
okay yeah
nice very nice
what the hell is that I just do a Bora
you know I forgot it's 2005 yeah no
that's fine
it's aged nicely peach my wife what the
hell is that pink thing is this hot
frosting yeah that was my guess you know
boiled frosting is saved your life you
could not dude you could not have done
that clutch by yourself I was imitating
a human and Dalek City yeah very nice
hello everybody says DJ walk sick hello
and welcome to my stream hello I want to
see Mario gobble a big plate of
spaghetti me too he did you know so if
he falls us asleep he will start to say
things like whatever Yoli my favorite
though she was peachy well he's not
gonna sleep this is an area because it's
really hot get oh I'm sorry we're doing
something together oh yeah he moves this
my neighbor he has iPad Nano everyone
does this for girls damn it we were just
here go up the steps
I can't how does a flame where is the
actual thing I mean let me oh let's do
the race has ever time do
so coupon okie-dokie try to get on those
leaderboards so yeah be Mario there
actually it's me Mario so it's below no
that's okay oh there's one else
I didn't oh yeah there is the slots all
right
I'm wrong always be right yeah earlier
we did like the jump rope so there are a
couple minigames that miniature games
miniature games full activities that you
can you know some casual competitions
healthy competition with actual people
let's uh if we gotta take this guy over
oh yeah so there's a mood right there
where a little twinkle star thing I
missed it oh there okay nice I've done
got a moon now we're also in a little
bit of a pickle ah dude I get it pickles
joke because food pickle
you should be fine now test court says
the endgame is so good dinner sir she
knows I hate Tomatoes I hate onions
music and I am more and more hungry I
could help more don't have the Red Queen
am i doing more damage I believe in us
yeah big Doreen says the floor is lava
sure so to do this race and maybe we'll
call it a stream that sounds about right
all right so I want to go towards this
rough little drop there
I can do it oh oh not good
no I can do it bro
Chuck later jelly bean all right let's
free run free run sighs well these can
be tough they can be really tough so
she's the computer cheats I look at
let's go that scoreboard just wanna see
I'll get you single-player okay it's
fine look at the scoreboard I'll kick
Rob out and then what you take a run for
it gets the better time that person buys
lunch oh whoa all right all right dude
I'm I'm dead serious I'm down I am
deadly serious
what a race bro he is such a brown
bearish spirit man all right rules you
do rules are simple race with raceless
to the goal and get there first
there's there's a price beacon at the
finish line got it all right well then
let's go hi my name's Cooper hope you
got your sneaks on
of course how does moving Kathy feel as
something player it was good you're
limited to like how far you can go but
oh you know it's funny to think too is
like salt yeah that's gonna be great on
a nice bird
a burning bottom Oh run good run
why was I not something was missing
there let me do it again
feel like my buttons weren't doing the
button thing uh-huh I'm blaming the
controller it's oh you know what it was
I was playing left-handed the hero of
Hyrule I was happy as moving it feels it
feels really great like I those dudes
are running on lava so that's the thing
right we were talk about this the other
day like these guys are a little Oh Pete
you know Mario has kind of new boo moves
where you can do a ground pound and get
okay you can get a jump boost right
after you do it oh God oh well all these
guys they're they're they're using
they're using yeah
performance enhancing mushrooms yeah
yeah see what I'm saying mm-hmm
something weird going on here it's like
a conspiracy what come on it's so nice
to know that the only one who's bad at
this or let's say good mister man cool
that was a bad move half the time when I
do these for the first time I just sort
of like trail behind the leader and just
let them do their thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah because like when you do it again
too
like for like a master mode Oh God
there's a gold sparkling Troopa who
shows up when you try to do like the
master race after he's a real jerk and
sometimes when you do it the first time
you're like man that was tough and then
you're like oh crap how am I gonna beat
the gold guy do you think I can't do it
but you do it like 15 minutes and you
start to see like okay I can exploit
this gap I can explain this opportunity
right it looks like we're not gonna get
to eat lunch you sure oh my god
you got the farthest and I think we said
the winner buys lunch so it's like
you're buying we said winner buys lunch
right this is so funny no Peter oh oh
yeah I forgot my wallet so I made
reservations for Ruth's Chris
see people said Cathy reminds me of what
I mentioned earlier in that I was very
careful to not write crappie instead in
my review I'm curious if there any
reviews out there that wrote crappie by
accident and haven't noticed the typo
yet or if there any tweets this what
stuff this is a tough one I will in Lion
I wouldn't lie
tough break bro you kind of sucked it we
watched you die over there look whoa
easy dude take a break take a breather
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
one more time that's it we'll call it
then we shall call it use the red tunic
it's a reference welcome to my interlude
[Music]
nope yep yep oh my God he's gonna give
me a hard time
hey all right yeah okay cool yeah screw
me right play by the rules okay I like
the racist yeah we worked it at the end
there but that was just a small taste of
Super Mario Odyssey I still have a lot
to play I've put in 40 hours I've you
know quote-unquote beat the game but I
have not finished the game just like
Zelda I got a lot to go I'm excited for
everyone to get a chance start playing
it tomorrow because it really is
something special and it's just one of
those games it makes you feel like a kid
again
it's it's an innocent fun video game and
it kind of reminds me why sometimes
they're important and not everything has
to be violent and dark so thank you for
watching Robyn yeah oh definitely thank
you so much to everyone who put up with
us we've got a lot of other Mario
coverage on GameSpot right now so head
on over there or check us out on YouTube
and as always thanks for watching have a
wonderful weekend
take care see you guys and see